I want to pull up this tweet from kit
Claren BG kit is a reporter for I I I
believe he's at
grayzone and he noticed something
interesting now I want to make sure I'm
very careful here as we start this this
is not hard confirmation of anything but
I do think it's something that Warren's
paying attention to he stated it's over
and there's an article that says Israel
rejects solinsky's visit time is not
right and this is from 10 days ago he
says what's also striking is prominent
pro-ukraine accounts are shuttering
rapidly such as UA weapons which claimed
to track Russian losses and garnered
almost a million followers wonder how
long it'll take for those flags to start
disappearing from display names uh
display names why do you think asks H2
he says infrastructure technology and
Personnel used to amplify these accounts
as being redirected elsewhere Western
Powers have no use of propaganda in
encouraging The View Ukraine will win
and needs to be sent weapons now quite
the opposite so this is an interesting
uh argument that we're seeing I think we
have uh this one he says absolutely
classic an anonymous high-profile Pro
Ukraine account that 10 days ago
attacked me for suggesting high-profile
Pro Ukraine accounts are shutting down
in a coordinated manner is now shutting
down calibra obscura says I will be
deleting this account within a few weeks
life is increasingly busy and frankly no
longer in a place where I want to
interact with things that I do every day
etc etc now it may be this is very very
interesting this is a tweet from October
16th when he put this out this is this
this a little while ago uh that he
tweeted this and then I think this uh
this next one was from just uh just
yesterday it could be that uh us
intelligence agencies have been running
scops Pro Ukraine accounts generating
massive numbers of followers not
necessarily Pro Ukraine like this UA uh
uh weapons uh uh account apparently was
tracking all information but the
argument would be yes but from a western
perspective when they say oh Russian
troops are dying it's is it the Western
number or the Russian number and then
you have this other account that's shut
shuttering as well perhaps one of two
things is happening and there could be
other things Intel agencies are running
scops and now that the money is being
diverted to Israel in the Middle
East we can't run these accounts anymore
so somebody who is in you know some kind
of scups division or private contractor
is told hey shutter those accounts we're
going to be focusing on Israel and they
go you got it oh sorry my family thing
happened or The Simple Solution perhaps
is Ukraine is over no one cares anymore
these look this this one account calibra
being like you know my life's getting a
little busy you might as well just say
what is going on in Ukraine no longer
Bears weight with me and other things
have become more important and that just
says whether it is the end of a sop or
not nobody cares about Ukraine it's done
yeah I mean it's not good for zalinski
either way he uh he was really counting
on more American money from what I
understand uh but I think it's
interesting I said this before Russia
won yeah I think in a lot of ways that's
true I think it's interesting to see um
the way Ukraine has fallen to the
background right I mean we don't see any
pro Ukraine protests it's not even like
there was a way for these two different
groups to team up it's just off record
and to a certain extent I credit that to
the fact that the people can really only
have one big thing in the news cycle at
a time it's very difficult for them to
have you know hold hold pay attention to
two things at once yeah it's like that
Meme where they insert one brain trip of
Ukraine then the next one is of yeah
Israel yeah I mean that's like the
capacity that that they can really just
go off of right if it is a
scop man I got a root Awakening we got a
roote Awakening for these Intel agencies
it's like all of the stuff that's been
happening with the manipulation on
social media that's uh uh propped up
woke left Psy psychotic garbage how how
do they expect to get military support
for Israel when they have themselves
coordinated with these big Tech
platforms to prop up anti-israel
sentiment I don't know I'm saying like
they're incompetent unless it really is
some deep 5D chess where they're like
first we make them hate Israel then we
make them like Israel and like I really
doubt it I think the people who are just
running this propaganda are just really
dumb I wish could Rebrand these scops
into something positive and caring about
places like East Palestine or or Maui
you know but they won't do that I don't
know my question like I'm like are they
just incompetent or are they just evil
like I just cannot I I don't think they
make money off these palestin the way
they do with this yeah for sure and I
think I think that's evil taking
advantage of a lot of incompetent people
you know and I think there is a a SC up
component to these things and there's
obviously also organic people who
latched on to the scop like maybe this
person who says you know I'm moving on
to other things is a real person we went
to this Tois restaurant called Barcelona
Barcelona in uh in Reston Virginia it
was awesome by the way we've been there
like three weeks in a row because it's
so good bar Barcelona Barcelona that's
how they say it in CIA Barcelona but uh
Barcelona is the name of the restaurant
and uh we have fans who uh who work
there and um I mean maybe they won't
like that I'm saying I don't know but
the people there were completely open
like oh hey you know like we're big fans
nice to meet you and then we went back
and this guy came and said he's like hey
man I love your show you're probably not
going to get that out here in Reston but
I'm a big fan keep it up and I was like
actually we've had like four or five
people here shout us out I think the
reason I bring that out I'm not trying
to Humble bre or anything the the point
is stop thinking you're alone everyone
thinks they're the only one they're
sitting there being like Oh that's Tim
pool I watch him I know no one else does
so I better just say it quietly no no it
turns out everybody there was super cool
so too many people are seeing these
scops seeing the manipulation on social
media and they're assuming wow everyone
in this country must secretly like trans
kids and Ukraine war and stuff I better
keep my mouth shut then it turns out
everyone actually agrees with you nobody
likes us wasting money on these Foreign
Wars there's been no justification for
why we're doing it shifting from Ukraine
to the Middle East now so if people just
start realizing that start speaking up
maybe we can put a stop to it this is
why I advocate for parents when they go
on play dates to immediately open up the
conversation about all the things you
care about the most so you can Whittle
down who you can have your kid
I think you should screen all your kids
friends that does make sense to me I got
an idea I got an idea here's what we do
an app where you can select things that
you believe in politically and then with
your friends it will only show your
political positions if you agree it's
like Public Square for I'm going to tell
my uh developer friend did you get that
so like it'll say what's your stance on
on pro pro pro-choice pro-life
Progressive taxes border control and
then if you don't agree on anything it
just doesn't share anything and yeah
dating app sort of for it's like Bumble
bu they had bumblebe F which is like for
women to meet other women and friends
I'm not actually serious for the most
part because like you can't Implement
something like this but the general idea
is you know you could you could input
your your political uh uh you know views
and then you don't have to worry about
someone being like ah know but that the
reality is you should just be able to
say Hey you know I don't like the fact
that in New York they're threatening
Jewish people
maybe should do that I think you're
probably just not as weird as you think
you are I mean I think a lot of people
feel like because they're not hearing it
on mainstream media maybe other people
don't want to talk about it but or just
afraid to say it out loud yet right
probably your views are not that
outlandish you're probably not that
dramatic of a person like you just
believe the things you believe and if
you treat it like it's normal which it
is other people will fall suit even if
they don't completely agree with you so
like when I say clouds are fake it's
fine well gives us something to talk
about right how are we going to get to
know how people feel about this
important is f uh I think the majority
of clouds are are
F I think they've been pumped into the
atmosphere or or created out of
chemtrails and they just get recycled
and it's just poison falling out of the
sky I think it's just water vapor well I
think a lot of them or I think some of
them are water build an intellectual
conversation about these differing
viewpoints I I think we've poisoned our
Sky to such a r idea uh I think we've
Cloud seated so much that it's hard to
tell yeah but they use lasers for cloud
seating now oh man yeah they don't need
to put chemicals up there maybe but I'm
talking maybe it's the Vintage clouds
you know they haven't really got they're
still in the cycle see is I a position
on clouds so this is very helpful to
help me to think learn about this topic
look it up look it up this is good we've
been seting clouds for a while um but we
doing different ways now more silver
iodide was the first way they did it and
then they started using um I think 10
years ago infrared lasers lasers to
Cloud SE it must be wild when you go on
playdates with your kids like how what
you launch into it's just like this
what's your uh view on clouds also our
kids don't need sugar exactly or or
Salmon's Salmon's bioengineered and part
bug so don't eat that either well also
people don't realize that lot of salmon
when it says wild CAU they grow it in a
farm release it into the wild and then
recatch it no joke wait so wild CAU it
can be a lie wait so then which one do
you get which one do you get cuz it's
not so a there's things you got to watch
out for are if there's a company called
like wild CAU salmon and wild CAU is a
brand name then it's Farm or if it wild
CAU salmon is a brand name is not mad
I'm not I'm not saying quite literally
that's the case I'm saying watch out for
brand names that masquerade as and look
for the colors of salmon too yeah yeah
uh if you look online you'll notice that
wild salmon is actually not so fatty so
if your salmon is pretty fatty it's
probably corn fed or something nonsense
but what they'll do is they'll raise
salmon in a farm in a big vat then
they'll dump them in the ocean then
they'll go with big ships and catch them
and say we caught them in the wild yeah
Fukushima is also a problem to recap uh
Salmons don't like corn they're not a
corn on a c the cob fan I think they
feed them corn I'm not entirely sure but
uh more back to the point the the point
I was bringing up initially is that with
this story uh uh potentially arguing
that many of these Pro Ukraine accounts
were scops the first thing I'd have to
say outside of you know the the context
of the story just in general is
absolutely the government is running
psychological operations on social media
to generate support for war yes so think
about all the accounts right now that
are demanding us intervention over
Israel and Elon Musk says he wants to
charge a dollar per year it's the only
way to get rid of the
Bots I don't know if even that will will
work all he's going to do is create a
more expensive Market for Bots yep right
now Bots are free you charge a dollar
what's going to happen is the barrier
for entry for bot making goes up and
then the bot companies and contractors
will just say so you wanted how many
Bots 3,000 H we're increasing our prices
by
340% uh because of Elon musk's you know
dollar so you got to cover the dollar
per account then you've got to cover the
credit card you know so it's an extra 15
bucks all in all it's going to cost you
three or four times more for your Bots
and and then these these organizations
go oh yeah no problem I can afford that
it becomes a business expense expense
mhm it's just more expensive to do right
and you think like governments are going
to abandon their scops on Twitter No
they've been working on those for a long
time no they love psychological
operations they've been performing them
on us for forever so he's a s up within
a SC up within a s up yeah yep that's
exactly it you don't know maybe the SC
up was the SC up the whole time maybe
the SC up was the SC up we made along
the way getting the S up to be exposed
was the actual
intention wow again I is inverted World
season 3 off I go it is kind of
hilarious that uh you know a few weeks
ago we were talking about how the I'm
looking at the
BBC's battle map for Ukraine and it
shows Russia controlling the land bridge
into Crimea and I'm like that's it they
got what they wanted and I'm I these
conservatives are like that's not true
they wanted all of Ukraine they were
going to invade from the north and now
all of a sudden it's like okay we lost
we're done everybody out mhm we're uh
we're no longer interest in what's going
on in Ukraine again I'd really like to
uh hear more from linski who is probably
so mad about his business venture
failing uh I I do think you know we
couldn't sustain this even with Janet
Yen saying we can afford two Wars
realistically no and also we could maybe
theoretically continue to pay for both
things I know uh speaker Johnson was
sort of there was a clip of him being
asked by journalists are you going to
send more money to uh Ukraine today but
the reality is as much as we need
financial it needs it needs the
attention span of the American people
right and if it's not there the money
won't follow they could print money they
want but it's the morale they need
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net